going to start with a question for eric
from
jade jade asks are there negatives
of in taking too much protein is the one
gram
of protein per pound rule good if i'm
trying to build a lot of muscle should i
be taking in
more than that yeah that's a good
question it comes up a lot
it seems to be really common that people
are concerned about excessively high
protein intakes and potential health
issues resulting from that
so um first of all let's talk theory
when you go on the internet you're going
to see people
saying all sorts of bad things about
protein some of the common ones you're
going to hear
one relates to the kidneys a lot of
people say the kidneys are going to be
unable to sufficiently clear the waste
products
that are made during amino acid
metabolism
and that the kidneys are going to be
unable to neutralize the acid load
resulting from
high intakes of amino acids and so
by extension people say hi pro high
protein diets are bad for the kidneys
themselves
and an offshoot of that people will
promote something called the acid ash
hypothesis
which is that if you have a high protein
diet
you'll be in this kind of systemic state
of acidosis
and that will cause bone loss as a
a mechanism to deal with that acidosis
and promote buffering
so those are two things that are
repeated very frequently
when you talk about high protein diets
um
but they're really not accurate they're
not true
if you have a pair of healthy kidneys
you should be more than able to
accommodate a high protein diet
so the idea that you're going to cause
direct kidney damage as a result of
protein intakes
within the ranges that we've actually
studied which you could argue go up to
even above 3 grams per kilogram per day
which is a lot of protein
and beyond i mean we've seen studies up
into the four range that have at least
found people to be generally okay
so basically your kidneys should be able
to handle about as much protein
as you would want to eat once you start
going above those
levels of protein intake that's just not
a very fun diet and i can't think of a
reason why you would ever
intend to go that high with your protein
intake
now when it comes to the acid ash
hypothesis the idea of
losing bone mass as a result of high
protein diets
that's been i think pretty soundly
debunked in the literature and if
anything
uh there have been more recent studies
that have shown that
high protein diets tend to have a
neutral to potentially a positive
effect on bone content and bone density
over the lifespan
so the idea that high protein diets are
bad for bone
it's not only been debunked but could
actually be wrong
in the opposite direction it's it's very
possible that
um high protein diets might actually
have a modest
positive effect on bone bone content and
density over the lifespan
so the whole kidney family of protein
myths
we can pretty much toss those out the
exception being
if you have an underlying kidney
pathology
you might want to talk with your
physician about whether or not limiting
limiting protein intake is a good idea
for you
so absolutely if you have serious kidney
issues there are some instances where a
high protein diet would be
definitely contraindicated and would
really put you at risk
and put your health at risk so but it's
important to separate those two things
out the fact that high protein diets can
be challenging
to a diseased kidney does not mean that
a healthy kidney cannot accommodate high
protein intake so those are two very
very different things
a lot of times you'll hear people talk
about potential liver issues with
protein intake
you know the liver is heavily involved
in
amino acid metabolism involved in
deamination
things like that um so the liver because
it's involved with
amino acid metabolism a lot of people
kind of
go with an extension of that and say
well if we're asking the liver to do
things maybe we're going to tire it out
and fatigue it and it's going to be
generally bad for it
much like with the kidney the evidence
that we have available would indicate
that
when we put a healthy person with a
healthy liver on a high protein diet
their liver seems to accommodate that
completely fine
there was a study fairly fairly recently
within the last couple years by jose
antonio
14 males crossover study for one year
um they were studying high protein diets
in the range of
2.5 to 3.3 grams per kilogram per day
for for pretty long
uh periods of time that they were
consuming these different levels of
protein intake
and they did look directly at various
liver and kidney biomarkers and found
no deleterious or harmful effects
that same lab they also did a study
looking at
intakes up to 4.4 grams per kilogram per
day
again that's just a horrifically high
protein intake yeah there's
really no reason to go that high you
you've essentially
maxed out the benefits of a high protein
diet probably about
halfway to to that intake you know i
mean yeah
anything above 2.2 grams per kilogram
you're really
kind of reaching maybe you can make the
argument if you're
a bodybuilder in contest prep and you're
five and a half percent body fat
and just trying to get the last couple
ounces of
glute fat off maybe you might hang
around
higher than 2.2 or three but yeah 4.4
grams per kilogram is gonna be a
miserable time you're going to be so
full
and satiated that you're going to feel
sick all the time so there's just no
reason to be up there
but in any case they did that study and
again they didn't directly look at
liver and kidney biomarkers to my
knowledge but
everybody lived so that's a good sign
yeah but but they didn't have any
serious adverse
events reported aside from just people i
don't know if they mentioned it in the
paper
but i'm assuming that people generally
felt like crap at least a few of them
one would think yeah so i'm not even go
back and check for that
i'm comfortable saying if we find 20
people and we put all of them on 4.4
grams per kilogram
at least six are gonna say i hate this i
feel gross all day well and probably
only three you're actually going to
strictly adhere to it
correct yeah due to that reason
yeah so the the reality of the situation
is there's a lot of these myths out
there about the kidneys and the liver
and even bone
health that high protein diets are going
to be deleterious or disadvantageous or
even dangerous
and if you are an otherwise healthy
person with no
underlying kidney or liver disease or
pathology
you should be completely well equipped
to handle high protein diets now
obviously i'm restricting that to the
levels of intakes that we've seen in the
literature so we've got plenty of
studies above 2 grams per kilogram
not many above 3 and
only one that i know above four in
humans
so obviously if you're if you're trying
to make a point
i've said this on the podcast before i
think but my general nutrition rule
is if you do extremely weird things
weird things could happen
so if if you push the intake of anything
beyond anything we've ever seen in the
literature i can't rule out the
possibility that something weird might
happen
um but but within sensible protein
intakes
high protein diets seem to be completely
fine um
and there are many benefits of high
protein diets so
if you're training hard obviously you
want to maximize the anabolic response
to training and you want to minimize
muscle loss during weight loss so high
protein diets are terrific for that
if you're trying to lose weight they
also have a great effect on promoting
satiety and fullness they also
have a high thermic effect of feeding so
generally speaking whether you're trying
to gain muscle or retain muscle and lose
fat
high protein diets seem to be a good way
to go how high
that's a good question generally
speaking
most people who lift weights are going
to be just fine in the 1.6 to 2.2 grams
per kilogram per day range
i think a lot of people push one gram
per pound because it's very easy
especially if you're used to to dealing
with pounds as your unit of weight
measurement
but um 1.6 to 2.2 grams per kilogram
seems fine
if you're a person who really
prioritizes your weightlifting
resistance training progress um
endurance athletes might get away with
slightly lower intakes in the 1.4
to 2.2 ish range but but that should be
a good range to start in and then there
are some special instances like i said
very lean people who are cutting really
hard might venture beyond
2.2 that's based on a review paper that
our dear friend
the good doctor eric helms wrote a few
years ago
one final thing i want to talk about uh
the gift that keeps on giving
the game changers documentary um
they had this awesome part i'm
paraphrasing but they basically
implied that if you ate meat
it would have a bad effect on your
muscle glycogen levels
and of all the
half-baked ideas that got kind of lobbed
out during that documentary
i think that was the most harmful to
me as a person and my heart and my brain
because i was like that's just the
stupidest thing
like it was operating under this
zero-sum
assumption that well if you're eating
meat you're probably on
what a ninety percent protein diet sure
of course
like there's no way a person could have
meat in their diet and also have
several hundred grams of carbohydrate
per day to completely replace
all the glycogen that they use
throughout the day i mean it wouldn't
shock me
if someone did like a very biased funded
study whereas like
one group eats a steak and the other
group eats like four cups of rice
it's like which one has higher glycogen
ooh the rice
yeah um i'd believe it
but uh yeah so man it's it's one of
those things that like if that makes it
through the editing process you kind of
just take the whole thing and throw it
out in the trash
you're like okay i i've seen what's
going on here
so um yeah don't worry you can still
eat high protein diets which do include
meat sometimes
and still manage your muscle and liver
glycogen levels
very effectively i mean this isn't
really my area but there's um
i'm pretty sure i've seen some research
looking at glycogen replenishment rates
and endurance athletes
where they test just carbohydrate versus
carbohydrate with
not like a tremendous amount of protein
but carbohydrate plus
some level of protein and if memory
serves those studies
tend to find either similar or slightly
superior glycogen replenishment
with carbohydrate plus protein versus
carbohydrate alone